it's been confirmed tonight that more
than a hundred and fifty thousand people
have now died in the uk after
contracting covid two years and one day
since covid19 was first identified in
china the uk has become the seventh
country to reach that terrible milestone
well here's the latest data released
just a short time ago another
146
390 new covid cases have been recorded
today as well as
313 new deaths within 28 days of a
positive test well that means the total
number of deaths now stands at a hundred
and fifty thousand
and fifty seven now political
correspondent rob powell is in
westminster for us tonight
rob
an extraordinary figure isn't it 150 057
deaths two years into a pandemic
pressure surely mounting on the
government now to respond to that but
they of course say that plan b was put
in place precisely to stop the spread of
this variant
yeah and i think what the government
will point to um when it comes to the
question over what happens next with
restrictions is the fact that whilst the
case numbers you outlined there
are far higher than they were back at
the january peak this time
last year the death rate is obviously
far lower this time last year we were
seeing um 1200 1300 deaths um that was
the peak per day this time last year
we're obviously at uh 300 today and some
figures that have been lower than that
in recent days despite confirmed
infections being the highest
they have ever
been so
whilst yes this is a sad milestone that
is being passed
i think the government will continue to
make the argument that the vaccination
programme and the booster campaign um is
bringing down death substantially and
indeed that's what the government has
said in a statement that they've put out
in response to this point being reached
in which a government spokesperson
has said that every death from this
virus is a tragedy and our sympathies
are with everyone who has lost loved
ones we are thankful for the collective
national effort and the hard work of
frontline health and social care staff
and volunteers for administering
vaccines to tens of millions of people
and keeping people safe their tireless
efforts have saved thousands of lives
but the pandemic is not over that's why
it's so important everyone continues to
play their part by coming forward to get
boosted now or getting a first or second
jab if you have yet to do so
now obviously the thing that has
radically changed how the government is
handling covid now is the vaccination
program the impact that has had
both on
hospitalizations and deaths so i think
that is part of the reason
why there is i think an increasingly
hardening view within government
about what uh bar needs to be passed in
order to justify
more restrictions i think just before
christmas your potential when less was
known about omicron as a variant and the
information the data was more uncertain
about its severity it did look like we
were on a path to potentially
tighter restrictions and potentially
curbs on indoor mixing i think we are in
something of a different place now
you've got a sense over the christmas
period that within the conservative
party and indeed within cabinet that
they put their foot down somewhat
around
going for more restrictions without
having the data there i think the
government has been buoyed somewhat by
data showing that yes whilst
hospitalizations
have increased
um recently the number of people
requiring the most intensive therapy and
intensive treatment has not necessarily
gone up at the same rate so i think that
is why at the moment the position the
government is in for england anyway
is potentially one that we may well not
see
further restrictions ramped up in the
short term um anyway all of that said i
think there are several big caveats to
that schools went back last week and
we're yet to see i think the impact that
that sort of mixing has on the case
rates and the hospitalization rates
we've potentially not quite seen
the full impact of the christmas and new
year period of mixing
on hospitalizations and deaths as well
so
it could all
need a course correction if that turns
out
to be bad but i think um as we reach 150
000 deaths there will be those that
potentially not today making this point
but will do in the future that of course
the impact of covid is not just counted
through people who lose their lives to
covet it's also counted through the
impact it has on everyone's lives on
their education on businesses that are
disrupted and i think that is why there
will need to be a very pressing case
made if we are going to see severe
restrictions put in again in the manner
that we have had in the last two years
yeah it is a complex uh picture isn't it
rob powell thanks very much indeed for
that